ừ ừ
à à
Xin
chào các bạn
hôm nay ăn sớm tí không biết các bạn
không nóng lắm à
à à
anh xin Có phải bạn từ vẫn bận lúc cậu
thỉnh thoảng các bạn mới thấy on Xem
trực tiếp được đấy chưa ta cũng cũng có
gì đó hai khi mà
còn nhắn
kiểu có nhắn tin chat chưa kiểu là live
chat thôi ngay nếu mà các bạn xem lại
thì các bạn xem lại chat nhưng nó chắc
nó an ủi phần nào
đi học không Kiều
à mình mình xem như thằng tự kỷ nó buồn
quá không ạ
ờ ờ
[âm nhạc]
anh tính trước hỏi mình mình Speed trả
lời trước mấy câu
ô ồ Hôm trước có bạn hỏi là dậy có dậy
với P mới với C không thì tết vmvc này
tặng Khía dậy đã thấy vợ MBC kết kết hợp
với OB đã thì mình sẽ
mắc nhỏ không do mình đi xa thì mình thử
ngồi lại gần nhé ạ
ở
nhà bây giờ mình sẽ gì gọi gì sát là con
Mic Đã chuẩn là
mình phải mua thêm cả cái gọi là cái
giá treo mic nữa để mà Mike kiểu giống
kiểu mấy chữ m là dí sát vào mặt đấy
chứ Bây giờ là mình mình toàn phải chơi
trò là mình cúi xuống nói chuyện với cái
mic
thì là nó hơi bị bé chắc thế à
ý tới mình đang kéo hết cỡ
mùi xác rồi đó Biết rồi thì
cái dậy mvc và hiện
tpm DC thậm chí
thì mình sẽ dậy vào trong khóa học
khóa học web tiếp theo
khóa của app để sẽ khóa học nâng cao
Bạn nghe rõ không ạ
anh nghe rõ hơn chưa hay là do mình mình
tự như mình chỉnh cái gì cho mik bé đi
nghỉ ở
anh alo alo bạn ngày rồi ông ạ
à à
ờ ờ
xe máy súng ở cái khóa web nâng cao ý
mình sẽ dạy cả Facebook này sẽ cảm thấy
Seo P
Xin chào các bạn thì để các bạn hiểu thế
nào mới C này thế nào Okay hướng đối
tượng này
cho MBC đấy mình cũng sẽ có tí ví dụ mà
mình cảm thấy khá tâm đắc với ví dụ đấy
bởi vì Ninh từng học mới xe trên mạng
cũng tham khảo rất nhiều mình mình
mình chưa biết mình nói các bạn chưa là
mình cũng thường hay rất xem vừa rồi
Mình còn phải lướt Lên vài trang nữa kể
cả trang
người nước ngoài cả cả trang tiếng Việt
từ món Xem cách người ta dậy một cái gì
đó để tham khảo sẽ là người ta dạy Cái
này như thế nào thứ nhất là mình kiểm
tra lại xem mà kiến thức của mình có đủ
20 like kiến thức mình có đúng hay không
là xử thế đôi khi bị nghi ngờ với nước
mến bởi vì mình bảo rồi đó là bản chất
là mình là
học từ bên cao lành nghề
trà xanh thì chắc chắn là lý thuyết của
mình có thể sẽ không vững lắm thận sẽ
mình quên vì cái đấy từ lâu rồi
lá
cây thực hành của mình nó chết trắng
đúng rồi bởi vì nó chạy được và chạy
được mà nó không ạ Nếu mà cái lý thuyết
cơ lý thuyết thì bắt buộc phải đúng Lo
thế nên là mình à
cho mình gửi kiểm tra lại các thứ cũng
như Xem khách người ta dậy truyền đạt nó
dễ hiểu thì mình hỏi đúng không ạ thà
người ta mà dạy kiểu khô khan quá nhưng
mình tránh thì cái dậy mới xe ở trên
mạng ấy lúc mình trai ấy thì người ta
nói rất rối rắm khó hiểu khó hiểu
ok thì mình khẳng định nó lý thuyết hoàn
toàn rất khó để mà
ví dụ
khác với nhiều người đang ví dụ
sự khác biệt bởi vì mình từng thấy một
cái ví dụ khá ổn trên mạng rồi về có ok
rồi
Anh chỉ còn MBC mình khẳng định Mỗi mình
mình chơi theo cách ga giàn thiết của
mpc cửa đấy và công nhận sinh viên mình
nghe thấy song có vẻ hiểu hết
Ừ nhưng mà hiểu là một chuyện xong rồi
áp dụng bài tập trận khác
ờ ờ
Em spo học tới phần nào thì người sáng
mắt lên được Vậy anh
thử ta là nếu nếu các bạn xem tại phần
mô tả bộ khóa học cơ bản ấy thì
khi Apple chỉ cần biết cơ bản là cái
toàn bộ FL cơ bản kia các bạn hoàn toàn
có thể
nhảy sang học lập trình được không Được
rồi nhưng mà lập trình đấy vẫn chỉ ở cơ
bản thôi còn nếu mà sang khóa học Were A
xanh khóa web chuyên sâu với thì mình sẽ
dạy các bạn về việc là
đòi rất nhiều bạn vào với nhau xô ngồi
tối ưu câu truy vấn hơn Vân Vân Vân Vân
ở chung ở khoa chuyên sâu đấy nó đúng
nghĩa là để các bạn lương 78 triệu ngang
bằng 15 thí nghiệm rồi và còn chỉ các
bạn với định những lời chung là anh khoe
chân xấu à Cái ngập tràn nhầm web chuyên
sau kia nó sẽ đúng là toàn bộ những cái
thứ mình có thể chia sẻ được sau khi mà
mình đi làm như thế này mình sẽ chia sẻ
được tất cả các bạn về mấy cái kiến thức
của mình
Vì thế nên là nó sẽ không còn là cơ bản
nữa nó thực tiễn luôn đúng ạ ạ
Ừ
cái có bạn hỏi bây giờ chắc là
à à
I will học chữ cho xong thì mình sẽ học
San Jackson em heo shuya mình cũng chỉ
chắc là mình chửi nước có nhanh thôi sợ
mà hôm nay nếu mở kỳ phí hôm nay anh sẽ
dạy cho xương luôn này xem có kịp không
sau đó thì mình
thì mình sẽ như mình đã nói thì mình sẽ
qua zoom để mà khi phỏng vấn Online đúng
ạ
Mình sẽ thi vấn đáp Online hoa rum
các bạn vẫn chuẩn bị mic dần dần đi đúng
không ạ ạ
Ừ cái cây bút bên mình trả lời Mấy câu
kia nhé có chữ cơ
không cho Y xuất khi bị lỗi không
Khi mà trách không đủ mạnh ấy ạ
Cái vụ mà giả sử mà các bạn Nhập dữ liệu
và mà nó bị lỗi nó hiển thị lên lỗi thì
cả Đấy là vài toàn được là là cái dụ là
giả sử các bạn Nhập sai cái kiểu dữ liệu
chẳng hạn họ sẽ báo lỗi lại thì cái đấy
là nó liên quan vietjack rồi nó con con
con sẽ trên và nó sẽ trả về một một cái
lỗi chính lạ
bộ phim không phải lỗi về cú pháp mà lỗi
về kiểu dữ liệu sai này cử kiểu dữ liệu
không hợp lệ Vân Vân ở ngọn thì
Ừ thì thì cả đấy mình sẽ không muốn
thích cơ để can thiệp và bản chất là em
cô ạ Khi mà mình chạy báo về cái lỗi như
thế
Ừ thì nó lại recepcion
mình chắc mình sẽ nói qua các bạn một tí
rồi ngày cái Samsung Bởi vì thực sự thì
trái sân Thì nó liên quan cái đấy Hãy
xin và alo thì các bạn tìm hiểu về hai
cái này thì kệ Alo tất cả lỗi cú pháp
thường hay là lỗ pháp nhiều hơn hoặc cả
lỗi kết nối Vân
cài Alo là khi mà các bạn mới chạy cốt
thì nó lập tức báo lỗi về đó bạn thường
là do những cải kiểu tung nó hỗ trợ mặc
định sẵn kiểm tra các bạn khoa mà những
cái lỗi đấy bị lỗi chính tả này hay lỗi
à
xin lỗi có thể kết nối lỗi không tìm
file gì đó
ở
đây con cái lỗi Samsung này là lỗi khi
mà các bạn chạy đến nửa cốc hoặc là chạy
cốt rồi Cô đang chạy Rồi nó báo lỗi lỗi
này có thể là giống như mình vừa nói lỗi
liên quan đến nhập dữ liệu vào nó bắt
đầu kiểm tra dữ liệu và và nó thấy sai
nó sẽ phản lại phản hồi lại này thì hoặc
gà không tin với bảng không tìm cái cột
này các thứ nói sắp sinh chứ anh còn ghế
rô này thì có thể là số số lượng cột
tương ứng với valeu cái số lượng truyền
vào nó không khớp nhau thì nó thể bảo vệ
lỗi về luôn chẳng hạn thế là sử là bây
giờ em các bạn Insert into một cái thuê
đồ đó các bạn chuyển ở đây hai cột có
một khó hay cản va luu các bạn sẽ truyền
11 giá trị như này đối ngoại nghĩa cái
này không phải chuyển nó sẽ Euro Tức là
nó sẽ nó có thể hiển thị ra lỗi ngay cho
các bạn về cái điều này còn ấy xếp sân
Thì là lỗi khi mà
phải chạy cốt rồi chạy cốt ăn đến nửa
chừng rồi nó mới bắt đầu triệu nó mới
đau đầu báo lỗi cho các bạn thực sự là
có vấn đề gì đó thì cái vụ đấy ở chính
là trà sữa khi in sẽ bị lỗi này đi thì
Ừ thì các bạn phải dùng trai cát là
là bắt lỗi
chai là thử không ạ và cắt là kiểu bắt
lấy
Ừ bắt lấy cái Assassins bắt người có lỗi
đấy để mà thao tác gì tiếp thì gì đó
thường là
dễ thương là kiểu trai cắt như thế rồi
thông báo thông bạn thường mà thông báo
theo kiểu là thông báo các bạn thì kiểm
tra lại với dữ liệu khi mí ra vào trong
nó gì sai cái gì đó
Ừ cái này nó lại không liên quan đến Hầm
chui cơ lắm mà liên quan trên sẽ xin hơn
ví dụ ví dụ về cái vụ chơi xin thì chắc
là để thuận tuần sau mình dậy các bạn đi
mình chị nào quay Thôi mẹ nó không nó
không nên dùng chi cơ để kiểm tra được
là không cho như rất là con nếu mà
bạn chỉ để cập về vụ là có chữ cơ không
cho giấc thì chính là buổi hôm nay mình
sẽ học đúng ạ
con trai cát ở trong mọi ngôn ngữ lập
trình cũng có không phải mỗi zava bạn
nhưng mà Đúng là mình hồi đầu tiên mình
học trời cao thì đúng là thầy mình áp
dụng bằng da thật
là chỗ là kiểu Java thì mình thấy à nó
tương đối cũng rất là gọn nhận được
đi đầy đủ chồng tờ đầy đủ nhãn chị ạ Nó
có gà hướng đối tượng này nó có cú pháp
các thứ thứ tồi
Ừ
nhưng mà hồi đấy thì đúng mình không
hiểu tại sao mình qua được một ra luôn
thì hồi nãy mình chuyên bán TP thì thấy
có vẻ trầm trước bởi phía hồi đầy Hồi
đấy chưa mình chấm nói ở đây không biết
được có bị cho là không không hẳn bóc
phốt người không biết nó cho Dì xấu xấu
không Nếu mà theo quan điểm trường mình
ấy chấm điểm khi dễ cực
bí đỏ uống mấy bé ông biết tôi sau đây
về sau tôi làm thầy Tôi chấm điểm thi
như thế nào
thứ nhất nha đó tôi luôn luôn Hỏi thế
Cái này hỡi vào giờ mới dồi cho mình Bây
giờ mình mới tâm sự xin lỗi gì nhé à
sau
khi mà tôi chấm điểm thi và giống như
thầy của tội từ nhan dụng nó ra ngay Tôi
sẽ luôn Hỏi sinh viên Đó là
à
đầu tiên là tôi sẽ cho tất cả mọi người
ra ngoài đã cho mọi người ra khỏi khỏi
phòng phòng thi bỏ tôi thi thực hành mà
Ờ
sau đó thì tôi sẽ hỏi trước là những
những ai muốn điểm trên 8D dai đấy Sau
đó thì
có đương nhiên là
một vài ông lắc bát theo kiểu là tiểu
mấy ông ấy tự tin ý mày nghĩ mình làm ổn
rồi Nó hư dữ
Ừ thôi bà mẹ mấy ông cứ ở lại đây á nó
không sẽ được ở lại nhưng cô ấy nếu mới
sẵn sàng trời luôn rồi mấy ông ấy nghĩ
mình mình muốn tìm cao thôi mình gửi
chấp nhận sôi tiếp theo tôi hỏi lại
những ông nào
nghĩa chỉ muốn là mình qua cái môn này
mà nghĩ mình sẽ nằm
đấy thì đương nhiên cũng lại có một vài
chú lác đác hiểu mấy ông cậu học cho lấy
giữ cho cái cái bằng rồi Gần họ gà làm
bài có thể có vài bạn tự ti là mà không
tốp hãy rồi tôi sẽ mời lần lượt mấy ông
ấy và trước xong rồi tôi sẽ chỉ cần thực
ra tôi chỉ cần lướt qua bằng vải câu mà
biết được mày có copy cốt của ông nào
đói không hỏi mua vài cái ra vấn đề ngay
đúng loại
đấy Sau đó thì có một vài âu của tôi sẽ
xâm trước nhưng mà theo theo dạng là
chấm dứt cho quá môn như cả là đúng là
ông ấy chịu khó khăn cần cù thôi chứ ông
ơi ở
đây là bài có thể chắc chắn trường rồi
mới biết gì đâu Nhưng mà nếu mà số lượng
người mà kiểu bị chấm trước như thế mà
đông quá thì tội cho tất cả cùng khi lại
ý nghĩa là như thế bạn sẽ họp lại Bởi vì
gấu Nếu bây giờ sử có một mình một hoặc
hai ông tự nhiên phải thi lại thì hai
ông ấy thì lại một mình buồn quá đúng
không ạ bây giờ sử có người mấy ông cùng
bị như thế thì cho học lại luôn cho nó
học cùng nhau cho vui hãy trở thế xanh
ra được
thôi chấm thì nó sẽ như thế thà đấy Sao
con tiếp theo để nó những ông 89 điểm là
12 này nếu không tàn gì ở tôi sẽ gọi vào
nhé tôi bà em muốn mấy đứa à
Ừ ừ thì muốn cho bao nhiêu cũng được Ừ
Thế 5 điểm nữa nhé
300 Em em em làm bài đầy đủ tốt rồi mà
35 bay đi đừng tốt thì ông ấy muốn mới
điều không phải nói chứ Bây giờ giả sử
khi phỏng vấn ông ông được hỏi là ông
muốn mức lương mà nhiều rồi kêu họ tùy
tâm thì người ta chỉ cho một triệu thôi
lo Nếu không phải tự đánh giá năng lực
của bản thân mình
cái đấy không phải tự kia mà tự tin mình
làm được rồi mình làm được thì mình phải
biết được là cái mức thưởng Xứng Đáng
của mình nó đến đâu một khi mà ông kiểu
kêu thì tâm cái hư thử người ta chỉ cho
đúng kiểu dạng là mức tối thiểu Thôi
về hỏi lại ông muốn mới được đấy sổ bắt
đầu mấy ông thì có thể nói là em mùng 8
đi đấy 8 điểm thì ra tôi chỉ chấm đúng
bài tập anh béo làm đầy đủ thuốc ạ những
cái câu hỏi trong đề thi thì bé ông chỉ
được 8 ý nghĩa là cái cách chấm của mình
có khác cho thấy ra có lời khác thì chấm
rằng theo kiểu đấy
ông làm đầy đủ thứ cả câu hỏi trong đề
thi rồi thì 10 Đúng không Mình không lời
cho mượn mình sẽ chỉ cho 88 và găng rồi
trí ta khi mà ông trả lời được một câu
nữa của tôi ngoài đề Không ạ là mười khi
mà không trả được câu sao rồi nữa ừ
Ừ đấy Thì đấy là
vợ nói thì bọn nó sẽ khi và bọn nó chọn
nút chín mười mới có ở chấm bài tập luôn
Nhưng hãy hỏi những thêm cái câu ngoài
ngoài đời thi có thể cố sao và kiến thức
mới luôn đấy cách dạy của mình Bọn nó
bọn sinh viên của mình thì những đứa nào
mà học được đấy Có vẻ khá thích minh khi
mình cho nhiều câu sao thêm này cũng như
là
Anh kéo nó kiểu thoải mái hơn để chấm
Không chụp Rập khuôn giống như như thầy
cô kìa kiểm tra từng dòng cốt một cái
thứ
ở Mỹ Nhân thỉnh thoảng bị sẽ góp ý bắt
bẻ khi mà nhìn qua cốt của
nhìn qua cốt của mấy bạn đấy
the face cho sao cũng được trên tán là
Ok đúng không Tôi chứ nếu thế thôi Chỉ
cho 8 thôi
cho tôi cho Tám thẳng luôn Tôi không
chịu thêm chấm cốt cơ cho về luôn miễn
dàng nhìn mặt của bạn đấy Chồng phải tự
tin chứ nếu mày ông nguyễn đạt đến nỗi ở
Mấy ông không biết cốt mà Mấy ông tự tin
được như thế thì tội cho ông Tám ông
xứng đáng được 8
điểm số ở trường mình mình chưa từng cho
nó quan trọng kể cả bằng cấp Ở ngành này
nó không bao giờ quan trọng
Thế em bảo ông Khoa ông được 10 ta thứ
hai được 89 Cái thứ họ chẳng thể hiện
được cái điều gì cả Ừ nhưng mà cái việc
Anh biết mình đang ở vị trí nào có thử
đấy mới ở thì yếu tố quan trọng mà mình
muốn dậy đề thi thử đối mình chưa rồi
quan trọng Đấy cả giống như ở đấy mình
còn đề cập thêm mà hồi đấy thi Zara mình
mình toàn qua thận chứ được 10 thì khẳng
định nói lại mình được 10 chứ dù mình
ngồi đấy mình gọn như này mình
có đấy Mình đi thực tập mà rồi đấy mình
xin phép thời mình mình có công ty tuyển
mình rồi mình đi thực tập em mình không
không đi học được
À thế à khi đi thì anh em mình vẫn phải
có mặt Vẫn giận đương nhiên vẫn phải có
mặt thôi mà ký ký giấy tờ các thứ chấm
đi em à khi trong trong cát bụi đấy tôi
ngồi làm bài đấy bằng pp ngoài bằng Java
xong rồi thay thay thấy mình thấy không
thèm nhìn bài mình luôn Thấy bảo đi thực
tập rồi à Tốt không Em có sự thứ tôi
thấy cho 10 ngày
em thay cho 10 cả lớp biết nhé nó chạm
vào cả lớp chẳng phải làm cái gì cả Bởi
vì uống dĩ là trường mình ở trường nghề
cái thằng cha kia ông nào mà kiểu đi
thực tập đi làm được rồi Chứng tỏ là Đạt
được đúng cái tiêu chí của trường nghề
mà đóng học đào tạo được nghề rồi có
việc làm rồi nhưng mà đòi hỏi gì nữa Thế
nên là mười không có nhiều ừ ừ
Em hãy 7 giờ một trong những cách dạy
của mình và các chấm thi của mình hồi
trước không lỡ như là mình không nói với
các chấm thi ở trường khác là nó bị như
thế nào nữa mà mình thấy ở cái đấy nó sẽ
khiến cho sinh viên chẳng có gì bất lực
khi mà đi chi cả kiểu rất là vui vẻ các
kiểu thoải mãi đến gặp ông bị đánh trượt
ông thoải mái ông ấy cũng phải nề
Ừ đúng ạ
Ê mấy ông chấm thi kiểu phải xả châu Âu
Kiểu khiến cho các ông giỏi cả ông rốt
cũng phải lề Cái thì đấy nữa tốt
em thậm chí ở kiểu Có phải bạn yếu lấy
mấy bạn đấy Kiểu bị chưa đấy mình cũng
hỏi lại bằng mấy câu cơ bản nhất không
có trong đề đó ạ hỏi mấy câu có bạn nát
Giả sử giống như ép quen này mình hỏi
lại là sử bạn đấy Bây giờ đang khi về
cái cơ thể nặng mình hỏi lại các bạn về
cái acetals hiểu mấy câu rất các bạn
thôi nếu bạn làm được mình vẫn cho 5
điểm chiều qua con Nếu mấy bạn này không
làm được nổi mấy câu đấy thế thôi Chưa
thấy phải chấp nhận không ạ Anh đang thi
thì mấy bạn ấy cảm thấy ở phục lỗi kiểu
mình chẳng biết một tí gì cả thì mình
chưa tới đúng rồi ông ạ
à à
Ừ cái điểm 9 điểm 10 với mình thì nó tìm
9 Thực ra nó mới khá lý tưởng
chính là mức kiểu trên rộng nó là mức
giỏi rồi và chưa lỗi là mức Hoàn hạn mức
là mình còn phải phấn đấu thêm Còn lúc
10 mức hoàn hảo quá mình rất hạn chế cho
bạn là mười chứ khi bạn ấy có phải rất
xuất sắc
AE theo kiểu bạn đấy phải phải tự học
trước rất nhiều thì mới mấy trả lời đúng
mới câu đấy mình mới trong 10 anh có thể
hôm phòng có thể hôm sau chấm Mình có
thể hỏi vài bạn nhỏ như thế chỉ sợ không
đủ để gian tới buổi hôm sau thấy rất là
giỏi đấy nếu con ra xử hôm sau Vừa là sự
cứ 60 người ta ngon như thế này 60 người
cùng sau hỏi thì phần đang vậy chứ không
phải chia hai buổi bởi Hưng không thể
một buổi xong hết mấy bạn được
Ừ ok Nói chung nha bây giờ bắt đầu vào
học nha à
thì mình sẽ trả lời câu này nói tào lao
không áp dụng thực tế
Ừ thì không đĩa bạn Này bạn này bình
luận cái nay ở trong cái video qua
QL 13
Em không biết bạn này muốn áp dụng thực
tế như thế nào Nhưng mà nếu mà kiểu à
Ừ cái việc mà bạn ấy bảo mình nói như
thế rồi ra mình cũng hơi tự ái một tí Ừ
nhưng mà
Ừ cái cái Việt áp dụng thực tế này thì
kệ SQL nó nó là không nó khó món dụng
thực tế lắm các bạn phải kiểu nhảy sang
lập trình với các bạn béo ruộng được Còn
không thì toàn bộ quyền nước này về cơ
bản nó vẫn là tào lao nó vẫn có dụng
thực tế Được
Không cho trả lại chúng ta luôn có những
thành phần có những người ghét mình rồi
đúng ạ Hôm hôm nay mình còn thấy
có một bạn của bất mãn các thứ mình và
góp ý vậy chửi lại mình mình đang sợ là
bạn ơi bê tông ngoài đời bạn đấy xin
mình làm nhìn cách nói chuyện kìa Bố đầy
quá Kiểu thế à à
à mình làm kiểm duyệt nhóm yootheme công
ty mấy lần cũng sợ như thế sợ là chồng
mình mình xử lý bạn ấy xong bởi vì nó
tưởng có một ông một ông này
khi bị trẻ trâu đến mức độ là ông ấy
inbox cho Tết trường của mình xong gửi
mail cho trường mình chửi
Ừ nhưng mà tôi vẫn cha được ra địa chỉ
nhà ông đấy nó số điện thoại ông đấy
nhưng mà tôi không muốn bảo công an thôi
à
khi tôi chạm nó mà Mấy ông ấy bị trẻ
trâu trong nhóm nên tôi chặn với ông ấy
so với ông ấy biết được tôi chặn rồi ông
ấy mới không ấy
mà Hết sống rồi chửi trường tôi xong rồi
còn là Nhắn tin inbox chửi mẹ tôi cơ tôi
bảo đấy Tôi muốn làm căng vãi chưởng
kiểu Nếu mà tôi thật sự tôi không nghĩ à
Tôi nghĩ là bây giờ mình nó chưa gửi
được ra nó vẫn chỉ hơi gây khó chịu tí
em bây giờ sửa kiểu làm là làm cho nó
kiểu căng quá số tự nhiên mình mấy cái
đưa đây nó
liệu án nó không có gì ở mất nó lại
xuyên nó cái gì lúc rồi mình 1 đổi 1 với
nó bị thiệt
cho nên là biển vô giá với
thì à
ở bên bu-rô thì toàn chơi cái trò là kia
phải phải chấp nhận chịu nhục Khi mà gặp
một cái thành phần như thế luôn các bạn
là nhất cái cửa thế
áo kiểu bỏ qua bỏ qua không không bao
giờ dám dây vào những cái thành phần như
thế
khi thận mình nghĩ là đúng đúng đúng là
mình phải nhịn mày đấy
dự án nghị thì không phải nhiều cũng
đúng nếu mình nghĩ kiểu gì hết
mở cửa sợ nhất mà người thanh niên này
mà mình hình lên đấy Kiểu họ có gì để
mất đầu mình thì có rất nhiều cái thứ là
mất đúng ạ
ở thời lại để đi hơi xa quá rồi à
à à
à mình mình mình sẽ sở nốt câu này Ờ cái
chiếc cơ DL hôm trước May mà mình không
nói câu đấy Hồi trước mình từng nói có
thể là thích rơi chỉ có 3 loạn nhớ hôm
trước mình không nên nói cái câu chiếc
ơi chỉ có bảo loại mà chích đâu có có 3
loại mà mình mình
mình biết chính sao thế
anh không Các bạn nhớ cái chị cơ Hôm
trước mình nói nó có chế cơ về log in
đăng nhập này ở
và
after xong ngồi y tế đúng không ạ
Bà hôm đấy mình cũng nói thêm đó là
cài after và in search of nó sẽ áp dụng
với dml nó không tác dụng vừa bql dml
tức à update Insert Delete đối ngoại
và bql tất cả Shake Thì hôm trước mình
trao lại thì đúng là nó còn thêm vào để
d l** Các bạn nhớ DL là gì không ạ
DL nó sẽ là press
enter prop up
tin tức là khi mà các bạn tặng bạc tạo
một cái gì đó khác sửa mà cái gì đó hoặc
cả lốp và
kiểu gỡ một cái gì bỏ đi đóng lúc bảng
help Index là cái gì đó thì cái DL nó
cũng sẽ chạy thì cái chết rồi này mình
thấy khó khăn cực ngắn thành ra là mình
sẽ không không dạy các bạn và đương
nhiên mình như mình nó thì mình sẽ mình
sẽ dạy buổi hôm nay sẽ là este đâu và
vẫn là về đây quy lồ ADN đúng không ạ ạ
anh không giọng của tôi là từ và Mike
đắt tiền lại
à à
ý
thì cái hôm trước chỗ mà các bạn nhớ bộ
hôm trước như thế nào thì hôm nay cũng
sẽ tương tự như thế không em Nhưng mà nó
sẽ khắc khác một tí đây mình sẽ cho các
bạn biết thế khác mình lại mở sao lên
nhá các bạn lại làm bạn nhìn thấy xe này
khi cái bài toán hôm trước đó là khi mà
khi mà nó cốt của mình chạy xong được
rồi Khi mà yêu suốt xong rồi thì mới cập
nhật dữ liệu ở bảng kia là không ạ cái
ấm chỉ là kế chiếc cơ nó chạy sau được
nó không cần phải can thiệp và chạy
trước nó không cần phải kiểm tra không
cần phải kiểm tra dữ liệu đúng hay sai
để mà chạy trước hoặc nó chạy sau được
cái trong trường hợp mà cần phải kiểm
tra trước thì sao giả sử ở đây là sửa
đây hôm trước thì các bạn nhớ về cái vụ
thật sự có bạn lớp này có mã này có tên
này có
số lượng sinh viên Các bạn nhớ không ạ
số bệnh như này và ở đây có bạn sinh
viên này có mã này có tên này xong ngồi
có mạ lớp này
Đây là sửa là hôm trước là mình làm theo
kiểu như thế này
Nghe thời sự đài mã là một này cái kia
này số lượng sinh viên là đang là không
nhưng mà khi thêm một bạn Long vào trong
mà lớp là một thì số lượng tăng lên đúng
không ạ Các bạn nhớ bài bài hôm trước
không ạ thì
ý
thì cái cái việc là khi mà thêm sinh
viên vào thì cập nhật số lượng sinh viên
Nghĩa là bài toán là mình cần nhật trước
hay cập nhật sau cũng được không quan
trọng nghĩa là cái này được thêm chị cái
này được cập nhật để không ạ không an
tâm hài cập nhật trước thằng ngày hay
sau đó nhắc Nếu mà ở Hôm nay thì sẽ làm
theo kiểu là bắt buộc phải kiểm tra
trước thay vì để số lượng sinh viên mình
sẽ là số chỗ trống đi là sự thế là sử là
một lớp thì chỉ được phép có 20 sinh
viên ở ạ
bây giờ xử hay mưa như này đúng không ạ
Cứ mỗi lần thêm một sinh viên mới thì số
lỗ trống phải làm sao ạ phải giảm nó
thành 19 chẳng hạn như thế đúng ạ là sự
bị thêm một bạn mới nữa nhé À một lớp 10
nữa này FPT này 20 này đúng gọn cứ thêm
một sinh viên nữa vào một lớp thì số lỗ
trống phải giảm đi đổ ngoạn A và trong
trường hợp nào thì mình không thêm một
sinh viên mới ạ
ở trong trường hợp nào
à à
Ê mấy ông đâu hết rồi
anh alo Mày có theo kiểu mày hay tôi
đang chỉnh
em hết chỗ chồng nó không ạ số chỗ trống
bằng không ạ Đúng rồi Nãy bạn đang mấy
bạn đang trả lời đúng là sổ trống bằng
không thì mình đã không cho thêm sinh
viên mới rồi đúng ạ Mình không cần phải
sữa trống nhỏ hơn không đúng ạ chỗ trống
bằng không là tốt và mình sẽ phải thông
báo trước một cái lỗi gì đó đúng ạ Ok
thì bây giờ đầu tiên mình cái tạo bảng
như này trước đi rồi ạ
Nhưng tại bà này
thì bồ lớp đúng không ạ mã
mã tên các thứ
mình không để tự động tăng nhé tím nhập
mã vào xong rồi thì mình xóa cần thử thử
đi nó tiện chỗ trống này
hiểu y ni đúng không ạ cứ tạm bỏ qua phụ
trách chung các hữu thứ II
Khi mà mình chạy đúng rồi đúng không ạ
tiếp theo là mình sẽ có bạn sinh viên
mình sẽ có mã lớp
ở đây sẽ là for key này
bạn lớp mình sẽ nối khóa ngoại
lớp tại cục mã này à
khi con voi bờ bây giờ đến lượt là mình
sẽ Insert a disk into lớp này à
thì mình sẽ có mã
tên chỗ trống
Alo
với tròn năm đấy cho ít để mà tí mình
lấp đầy nó nhanh nóng bọn mình không cần
lại Insert thận 20 bạn đi làm thì cả
hai này cái bên đấy cũng có 5 và sự đang
có hai lớp bà đều 5 chỗ trống ngoãn Thế
sao for love trước đi
ê kê các bạn thấy s.de bằng năm rồi mình
sẽ in xơ cả sinh viên đã
khi
mang thai ở mà lớp đúng
đây là sự đè Long Anh Tuấn Huyền ông ạ
đây sau đây là cùng vào lớp 1 chẳng hạn
thế
à à
Ừ thế bạn thấy là bây bây giờ Bây giờ
mình chỉ quan tâm câu select luôn à
thì các bạn thấy là xuống nó không hề
được cập nhật sắp sẵn rồi chưa hề được
cập nhật Khi mà mình thêm sinh viên mới
là đúng ạ thì thành ra thế này là say
mất rồi đúng không ạ
Ừ cái này cái cái này thực tế là
những kẻ thực tế là mình một là mình sẽ
phải luôn cao luôn đếm lại số sinh viên
ở trong một lớp để mình kiểm tra xem lớp
đấy đủ chỗ chồng hay chưa để mà mình nữa
không không cho đi sát vào các thứ thứ
nhưng mà thay vì mỗi lần Thế mình phải
cao nhưng thời gian mất công thì thai
bây giờ mình sẽ lưu lại luôn Hàn 5 chỗ
trống các thứ thứ sau đó thì mình sẽ có
lỗi lầm ý rất vào mình sẽ cập nhật chỗ
trống cho cả lớp đấy và mình chỉ kiểm
tra sổ trống cũ thôi đúng không ạ chỗ
trống cũ thôi không phải sổ chồng mới
dọn đấy Thì bây giờ mình sẽ có câu lệnh
là mình tạm phải delete
sinh viên
xóa xóa hết đi nhá Bởi vì chắc chắn ạ
Bây giờ nó không còn đúng nữa không ạ
bây giờ tạm trữ cơ đúng không ạ chích
trên bảng sinh viên rồi Hoặc bời mình
thêm sinh viên mà
thêm sinh viên này on sinh viên ispace
a
research has revealed and Phạm Liên Khúc
Thi
cái bài toán ở đây Thực ra nó giống như
hôm trước mình học mình biết rồi đó là
mình sẽ lấy cột mã lớp từ bản in rất
thực đó ngọn sau đó thì mình sẽ lấy số
chỗ trống cũ cũng Á đúng ạ
sửa đây năm nó gọi để làm đi đúng ạ là
sử
em giả sử đay nó như thế mình sẽ lấy chỗ
chồng cũ này rồi Kiểm tra xem nó có bằng
không ấy Không nó Hoặc
nếu nó bằng 0 thì mình sẽ trả về lỗi
luôn đúng không ạ con nếu mà nó khác
không thì mình sẽ phải như nào mình sẽ
phải Insert phải Insert Vì sao rồi vì ký
giúp nó thay thế luôn cả công suất mình
rồi nghĩa là Xóa hẳn có Kinh Xét Mình
rồi nhé khi chích cơ chạy Xong ấy thì
mình sẽ không ý sớm được đâu nên là mình
muốn thì mình phải ghi lại câu Insert ấy
em mình sẽ thử cho các bạn xem nhé
mình giả sử mình có sẽ lexar for your
thật để các bạn xem qua bảng này như thế
nào
chú chạy này
ở đây mình sẽ mình như hôm trước mình
dậy là cái rất nhiều bản ghi nó sẽ khó
gì Sơn một bản ghi không ạ Mình sẽ làm
đúng như thế Mình sẽ đi sớm một bản ghi
trước thì các bạn biết chạy này
Ừ đấy thì các bạn thấy nó sẽ đi xuất
đúng như thế này những cái gì mình nhập
vào thì nó sẽ và ánh sự thật đúng ạ và
các bạn xem lại về selexol fours như này
thì các bạn thế à
anh không hề ý rất được đúng hoặc buồn
vì a như mình đã nói ít of là nó sẽ xóa
nó loại Bỏ hẳn cái câu ý rất mình rồi
nên là nó không nói chuyện là các bạn
vài Insert được đâu thế nên là bây giờ
thứ nhất là mình cần làm đây gì mình cần
ạ Lấy cái mã lớp này là Nhưng mà lớp
mình sẽ giữ vào đúng không ạ sôi lấy
chồng cũ một cái bạn của cái lớp đấy cho
mình kiểm tra là ngoại mình kiểm tra
mình sẽ có khái niệm là đi kraddy Tại
sao biến
số chỗ chấm cũ
anh Thuận chế mình cứ ghi đầy đủ cho nó
chuẩn đi đi clan
mã lớp mà mình sẽ in xơ và không ạ kiểu
này bằng Shake mã love for instance này
đó thì sổ trống cũ sẽ bảng Shake vẫn là
gửi này
bằng Shake số chỗ chấm
for love where mã bằng hạ lớp này
chồng mẹ khá dài không ạ đây Tức tức là
mình sẽ lấy ra như thế này và sau đó thì
mình sẽ làm gì mình sẽ kiểm tra lại ít
theo đấy ông ạ là kiểm tra là nếu nếu
cái sổ trống cũ bằng không thì mình sẽ
in ra lỗi
số chỗ trống cũ bằng không thì mình sẽ
Rin ra một cái lỗi gì đó
là
lớp này hãy chỗi trở lại
cho nơ lòng trước đi chạy thử nhé
khi khai báo lỗi vì cái này đã tồn tại
Đúng không các bạn crash or enter này ạ
khi đó bơ mình thường đi sớm này ạ
Ừ vậy ăn sát thủ lên sẽ chắc chắn được
bể sao bởi rõ ràng là lớp của mình đang
có
em đang có chỗ trống mà đúng không ạ
đương nhiên là không không không thông
báo không thông báo thất bại thôi đúng
không ạ Bên mình thự trong cái eo đấy
thông báo này à
- xuất thành công đi
ừ ừ
A chạy
ở 30.000 sẽ lại đi xuất thành công đức
như là mình báo thì cho vui thôi đúng
không ạ Các bạn thấy rồi đó là mình chưa
chạy lại câu Insert thành ra nó vẫn
không gì xảy ra cả và mình chưa làm vụ
cập nhật số trông nó không ạ
Ừ
nhưng mà bây giờ giả sử mình đi xuất một
cái lớp nào đó thì chắc chắn ạ ạ lớp đấy
không nghe có có chỗ trống mà đi sự đây
web ạ
hàng mình đổi đây là không chỗ cho đúng
không ạ
à à
cho anh à
khi bơm mini Shark thử bạn lo mình không
đốt thứ ba này các bạn sẽ thấy da lớp
này hết chỗ rồi đó ngoại thì chị cái lỗi
như thế người dùng dễ hình dung hoặc ạ
a nhớ bài toán là mình không không phải
hiển thị thế cho vui không ạ Bây giờ
mình cần làm là gì bây giờ giả sử lý rất
thành công thì mình phải cần nhờ chỗ
trống cho nó còn lúc mình rất thất bại
thì thôi bỏ qua đúng không ạ ấy nghĩa là
mình sẽ phải cập nhật và cái chỗ khi
mình giữa thành công này đúng ạ
thì đây mình sẽ làm gì mình sẽ cần à
thì mình sẽ cần ở đây đó là mình sẽ phải
answer vào và cập nhật lại sổ chỗ chấm
đóng ngoặc các bạn thì làm cái nào trước
cũng được vợ cập nhật trước sau đó thì
sao cũng được
bạn trong trường hợp này cập nhật trước
cũng được đi update lớp này xét chỗ
trống này bằng số chống - một đống vọng
Where mã bằng mã lớp
bạn lớp trên này đúng không
và sau đó thì mình sẽ Insert into sinh
viên cái đoạn này mình thấy được ra hơi
mất công một tí
ở đó sao đó là à
cho cây Nếu mà giả sử mà mình làm mới
của nông dân Kiếm thứ 2 thì
Anh ở trong mảng sinh viên có cột nào mà
mình sẽ phải
đi clip tương ứng lấy cột Thế mình làm
mới của nông dân nói như thế này
Ừ mình chiếu cốt mã của T nữa bị xử là
phải đi clan này
mã kiểu này bằng nó cần copy cái đoạn
trên này
các bạn hãy nó sẽ giữ ở mức ông một đoạn
này
vào đây là tên này à
Anh tên
devit không ạ
50 này à
khi mà đây sẽ là
e-blue
mã
tên nhãn lớp
đấy như này em mình sẽ thử lại nhé
em thành công giống
em xem lại một con nữa chắc này đang số
lượng ngay các thứ đúng không ạ Đi sớm
này
các bạn được để mày cái dâu cập nhật này
đưa nó không có đúng không kệ thôi
đó như thế này cái này thì các bạn thấy
là bị lỗi em bị lỗi đấy bởi vì sao Bởi
vì à Mình đang sắp vào tháng thứ 3 thoại
vẫn được cập nhật tại sao như thế rõ
ràng là nó Chỗ này hết lớn này hết chỗ
rồi nó phải ngừng ở đây đúng không ạ lại
em này phải ngược lại đối ngoại cho eo
này nếu mình không dùng đóng ngoặc ngoặc
theo nó không quả bugi về em ấy thì
em này nó sẽ dừng tại đây thôi mà cái
đoạn nặng dưới vẫn tự chạy cái bây giờ
mình sẽ phải có đây biggie này
Mẹ này
vào đây thế này đi ghi này
tên này
đó lý do mình Tab và như này Các bạn
nhìn chú chó bên mình lại trả lại phát
nữa này mình tải tạm brady nhá delete
delete for love luôn đi
rồi dữ liệu giờ không còn đúng nữa nhà
mình phải anh sợ em ạ đó đây mình tạo
lại nói chuyện này
thì
các bạn để kỹ lại Nga làm 50 ạ đến sẽ
vào này
lúc này hết chỗ rồi Không đi sớm được
mày không sẽ được đúng ạ Đổi sang lớp
thứ một này đi sớm lại đi xuất thành
công đó ông ạ xem bạn này đó số lượng
thay đổi đúng ạ anh đấy trong y xác thực
ở bển sót được không Bạn này mình nhớ
không lầm mình như là bạn bè sinh viên
cũ mình này đại học trước rồi không
không không chơi cho họ trước
Ờ ở chỗ là đại khái nó như thế các bạn
vừa rồi cũng hiểu qua cách làm thấy cốt
của cái chi cơ Easup này nó dài hơn
không ạ dài hơn ở chỗ nào gầy hơn ở thứ
nhất à vì phải kiểm tra dữ liệu xem là
nó có hợp lệ hay không đúng không ạ Nếu
mà nếu mà không hợp lệ thì mình nên Hiển
thị một cái lỗi sau đó không làm gì nữa
đúng không ạ còn ngược lại là nếu mà hợp
lệ đúng không ạ thì mình có thể thông
báo thành công tùy nhưng mà mình phải
cập nhật lại số lượng cũng như là phải
phải mất công yêu sót lại
Ừ đúng rồi phải mất công phải ghi lại có
ý xuất thì các bạn thấy là cái cái cái
mệt mà mình vừa đề cập ở đây cái mệt
nhất đấy nó lại là cái vụ mà ở trong bạn
sinh viên này có bao nhiêu cột thì các
bạn sẽ phải tốn về việc là đi claire bao
nhiêu lần như này và cái này còn áp dụng
chỉ cho in xuất một mặt ghi thôi nếu mà
các bạn nghĩ rất nhiều bạn sinh viên
cùng 1 lúc thì những nhớ hôm trước mình
có đề cập thì dỡ trả lại cái mã lớp nó
sẽ bây giờ nó sẽ là dạng nhiều ba chị nó
nhiều nhiều mà lớp cùng lúc cho rồi kể
cả ý rất cùng một lớp thì chắc chắn mạnh
mã lớp 7 cũng lặp lại mình nhiều nên
kiểu y là không đúng này Đấy và từ đây
nó sẽ dẫn đến rất nhiều cái dưới nó sẽ
không đúng nữa đúng loạn thành ra có
chính sách này chỉ hợp cho một bản ý
thôi
tâm tư như này thì các bạn phải là cái
này thì ra là nhỉ Cái này chỉ áp dụng ở
bên in Ừ đúng ạ Con đi lấy thì sao đi
lấy thì đương nhiên dễ rồi có bạn cho
chạy đi lấy bình thường thôi nhưng mà
cũng phải cập nhật lại số chỗ trống cho
họ đúng ạ Các bạn nhiều không ạ thì rõ
ràng là bây giờ sửa xóa đuổi học bạn lo
mày đi đúng không ạ thì rõ ràng là số
chỗ trống này nó không thể Nó còn là bốn
nữa đúng là nó không có nó 4 nữa nó phải
như thế nào ạ Nó phải nó phải khôi phục
lại như cũ đồng bọn nó sẽ phải tăng lên
là năm thì cái vụ đấy thì thơ ca không
cần phải ý sẽ hợp đóng ngoặc
khi mình không cần phải kiểm tra xem ở
kiểu các thứ hấp lễ không mà mình chỉ
đơn giản là gì mình là lấy mã lớp của
những cái bạn mà bị đuổi đấy đúng ạ Mình
sẽ mình sẽ cập nhật lại chỗ trống tăng
lên là xong ngoại nghĩa tăng lên trước
hay sau không quan trọng Miễn là tăng
lại cho nó là được không ạ chi cái đấy
Mình sẽ dùng à chích cơ after chứ không
cần phải ứng sẽ được thì đỡ tốn nhiều cả
mình phải ghi lại câu lệnh thứ đối ngoại
ạ
Ừ nhưng mà còn kể vụ Nếu mà giả sử là
bạn Long này bạn đấy lại chuyển sang thể
lớp mà đang chỗ trống bằng không thì như
thế nào để chọn cái đoạn này lao đầu này
bạn này cốt dứt dài luôn này nếu để ý kĩ
nhá
Ờ nếu mà bạn Long đang ở lớp này nó ạ
Bạn lo đang ở Wow đối ngoại bạn nhảy
sang p mpp hết chỗ trống rồi đúng không
ạ thì
Ừ thì rõ ràng là không cho nó đổi đúng ạ
thực tế là như thế còn bây giờ nếu mà
mình Viết cốt đấy thì mình sẽ phải kiểm
tra chỗ trống của cái lớp mới đóng ngoặc
cả lớp mà bạn ấy sẽ nhảy sang là chỗ
trống là bằng bằng bao nhiêu không ạ Nếu
Bằng không thì dao bằng không thì mình
lại phải Insert lại vào gái
à không không không không cần in shop
bởi vì yêu sẽ được thay thế mất rồi
khi đun nóng không không cần ấy sẽ lại
nó nó vẫn sẽ thì mình cần giữ nguyên
thôi mình thật Tự nhiên thôi còn nếu là
ra sự mà thành công thì đúng là mình
phải cập nhật lại cái thằng chỗ chấm này
phải tăng tăng nó lại lên thành 5 này
đâu ạ và thằng này thành một như thế này
á Không không trăm trang trong trường
hợp đúng nhá trong trường hợp đúng thì
nó sẽ thành công hay gì đó bọn
mình thì thử luôn nhỉ nói nhiều thì hơi
bị lý thuyết quá
xưởng sinh viên này
là sử mình cứ đổi bạn từ
bạn từ
lớp 11 xa nước thứ ba rồi em được không
nó không ạ
on sinh viên này
mấy ông ấy giờ có vẫn hiểu ông ấy nếu đi
lặng mà không biết mấy ông có tài mà
không được buồn mà ừ
ừ ừ
anh em mình sẽ lấy số à Lấy mã lớp từ
bảng
Ừ từ bảng mà mình sẽ kiểu
Ừ Từ từ
ở đây sao mình cứ thử select from list
và xếp xà phòng đi tất cả bạn dễ hình
dung địa ạ
thế này
A chạy
à à
3.hd sinh vn sex đã lớn bằng
3-way mã sinh viên Mã sinh viên nước
ngoài mãi một này à
A chạy
Sau đó các bạn thấy là
khi tóc bạn insta tết thì tức à Cái dữ
liệu mới của bạn đấy sẽ thay thế lại
bằng 350 cũ là bằng một đúng không Thì
Tức là mình phải kiểm tra cái chỗ trống
của của cái lý bạn lớp ở trong mạng xác
thật đúng không ạ
đề tài đi Clans
mã lớp mới bằng
kiểu này bằng như này rồi bây nhiêu lần
này mình sẽ lách mà lớp này
tương tự Thế thì sẽ có ở đây em ạ lớp cũ
này
ngày để tật này
thực à là cái đoạn lấy mà lớp cũ này
chưa cần làm vội mà mình cần làm ở đây
là gì mình cứ ghi nó pass để các bạn dễ
hình dung nhé
Lấy mã lớp mới
tư bản ký sự thật này
in search vật
lấy số chỗ chấm
từ lớp mới công ạ
từ lớp theo mã lớp mới đi à cách kiểm
tra số chỗ trống
bằng không Đây là tôi tôi đang chỉ mới
phong cách kiểu diễn giải cốt theo kiểu
là Đây gọi là gì
cốc giả có ra cũng không đúng lắm Tôi
nhớ cách nói cậu đây có là một hình thức
kiểu cho toàn lập trình hết á
ở đây là không Mình quân xử cách gọi cái
này là gì rồi nghe Nói chung nó sẽ giúp
bằng ngôn ngữ tự nhiên
anh kiểm tra chỗ trống bằng không ạ thì
à nếu nếu đúng không ạ Nếu đúng
thì mình sẽ làm gì nếu đúng thì mình sẽ
mình chỉ việc là thông báo lỗi đúng ạ
thông báo lỗi thế thôi ông ạ Còn nếu sai
thì sao Nếu sai thì
Ừ
nếu sai thì mình sẽ lấy mã
ở thời tiết là lấy lấy mạ lớp mới này
mà không thấy mặt đâu đó bình tĩnh
anh ở đây mình sẽ cập nhật trước đi cập
nhật số chỗ chấm
3 - 1 theo mã lớp mới I
khi mà đây sẽ là lấy mã lớp phủ này
từ bạn để lực
và mình cập nhật chỗ chấm
khi cộng một bóng mạnh
theo mà lớp cũ
và sau đó thì bây giờ mới là một loa cái
việc là mình delete
anh à không Mình có thể không phải đi
lép âm in search mình chỉ ra updates
cũng được
ở những cái việc
chỉ là ấp lết các bạn còn đôi khi đôi
khi không biết được là cái cái updates
này nó không áp tiếp mã lớp Nó tết mũi
tên mà nó thôi thì sao đúng ạ thì rõ ra
mấy cái này nó lại hơi bị sai sai tí
Ừ
Để tôi giải thích tại sao sai biệt là sử
bây giờ nhá trong trường hợp này tôi đổi
một tên bằng
nóng hacker em ạ
thì rõ ràng có liên quan việc là lớp lớp
tôi cần thay đổi đâu đúng không ạ lớp
tôi vẫn giữ nguyên mà nó không ạ thì tự
nhiên lại Cập nhật lại mã lớp của tôi
làm gì đúng không ạ thì bây giờ trong
trường hợp cái dễ cái dễ của tôi thường
này làm đấy thì mình sẽ luôn lại xóa
anh xóa sinh viên nó đi theo lớp theo mã
thì nó sẽ luôn Đúng này Xóa sinh viên
theo mã
mã này lấy từ đâu mã này đứng và lấy từ
yz thật thể đi hết thật cũng được bởi vì
rõ ra là mình không cho phép ra sự mình
không chọn không cho phép đổi mã
Ừ thì mã sinh viên nó sẽ là duy nhất của
bọn mình sẽ xóa sinh viên Mã rồi mình sẽ
in sót lại
sinh viên Đông ạ theo toàn toàn bộ dữ
liệu
lấy từ chính xác thực
tại đoạn này bay não này
về bản chất Các bạn nhớ vụ update nó sẽ
bằng gì họ update sẽ bằng Delete + visa
mà không ạ
thì đấy tội đang làm đúng như thế đấy Đó
là như thế này và ít lại khi nó sẽ hợp
lý hơn để các bạn đỡ phải kiểm tra xem
nó rõ ra là nó update nó biết những cột
nào những trường nào đúng ạ phức tạp ta
thì mình sẽ làm thì cậu như thế này
không ạ Không có vảy dày đấy ông ạ mã
giả
ở
đây thì mình sẽ ít ở đây đó ạ Ở đâu thấy
chỗ trống trước decrit số chỗ chấm Cái
này
cái này
snack xuống chỗ trống home
a list for love chứ phòng lớp Where mã
bằng mã lớp mới
sau đỏ đít chỗ trống bằng không thì ghi
này e này mình thông báo cái lỗi luôn
không ạ
ở lớp này hết chỗ rồi ông ngoại
ở
đó xong yêu đây lại đi ghi này em này
cho mình biết hết cốt ở trong này đây
với ngược lại thì mình sẽ làm gì mình sẽ
cập nhật số chỗ trống đấy đúng không ạ
Mình sẽ update
lớp sét số chỗ trống
Ờ như bạn kia làm nhanh thì nó sẽ trừ
một ngày cũng được khi kiểu này sẽ bằng
chỗ trống - mồ thôi đúng không ạ
Where mã bằng mã lớp mở mới
vào đây lấy cái mà lớp cũ này Sao lại
cập nhật đó ông ạ
em copy này
cũ này
và bây giờ mình sẽ xóa sinh viên không ạ
Mình sẽ là Blade for sinh viên
Where mã bằng
có thể các bạn không cần phải khai báo
biến các bạn ghi kiểu này cho nhanh cũng
được Sứ Mệnh mã for a
à
à directed
đó sau đó nhưng mình lại chạy cay rát
không ạ
Insert into sinh viên này
mã tên và mặt lớp
ba lô
cái đoạn này rất rất dài này các bạn sẽ
thấy là mình mình bản chất là mình lấy
đúng mỗi mã lớp mới đúng không ạ thế
Mình chưa đi từ hai cái này là Sử là cái
thằng mã của sinh viên không thay đổi
thì mình cứ đi lại ở trên này chứ lại
nhá mình đi cờ lê ở trên này đi Ừ
à à
a mã sinh viên hải ngoại in
ra cái này không quan trọng đi là sự thế
mình đây đổi đổi đây mã sinh viên Giả sử
Trong trường hợp mã sinh chứ không thay
đổi nhá Thì mình vẫn phải thêm một lần
nữa phải đi trở lại nên
selected from
xác thực
cái tên mã lớp này à
Anh không thể nào thế rất dài không ạ
ở đoạn này mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn có
thể nhắn rất rất nhiều
đây press enter này
như là để các bạn làm được cái nhắn thế
các bạn phải hiểu được cái cơ bản đã
không ạ Mày hiểu cơ bản đã đây mình đã
hướng dẫn xong đây đầy đủ các bạn ơi ơi
mình thử update nhé các bạn thấy
nhà báo nhà được bảo không quan trọng
nữa đâu mà mình phải xem lại thực sự nói
như nào
có cắn có cách để tắt cái báo đi
khi sex
à À đây đi xe mày
em đổi sinh viên Sang
Ừ đấy các bạn thấy đổi sinh viên kiểu
ngay đúng
nghe rõ là mình không đổi mà lớp thành
ra là số lượng sổ xố chống nó vừa thay
đổi đấy nó là tăng lên lại năm xong rồi
nói lại giảm đi đấy nên thành ra là các
bạn hãy nó vẫn giữ nguyên đúng không ạ
Nhưng giờ mình thử đổi mã lớp Xem đổi mã
lớp bằng 3 - hạ trại này
từ lúc này hết chỗ rồi đúng không ạ Các
bạn thấy là sinh viên Vẫn như thế chả gì
thay đổi cả đúng không ạ bé đổi mã lỡ
Sao mạng hay được ạ như này
thì các bạn thấy là Ok ngon rồi nó nhọn
Anh tốt này nó khá là dài một tí không
là khá là được rất là giỏi đấy và như
mình đã nói toàn bộ Cái này kiến thức
đây mới trẻ cơ bản
Ừ ông lão thầy choáng quá sim ông nên
dừng lại đến loại này được rồi Bây giờ
tôi nhảy sang cái nâng cao Mày không
muốn sáng hơn này
ok đấy vừa rồi là giải quyết xong toàn
bộ với cơ bản và rất là dài dòng các bạn
thế à Nó rất là nông dân nữa dài đúng
không ạ
bây bây giờ mới nhảy sang cái hay hơn và
phức tạp hơn này rất là giả sự là bây
giờ mình sẽ đi sớm đi đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ in search
rất nhiều sinh viên cùng 1 lúc thì mình
sẽ như thế nào
khi tôi thấy cốt này dài quá tôi phép
xóa đi nhé mấy ông mấy ông có xem lại
được mà không phải không xem lại sau nha
Tôi nhìn cốt này cho tôi lại sợ lắm
Bây giờ
mình cứ Delete hết đi này xuống chơi này
ông ạ thì sẽ tại lớp này không ạ Bây giờ
giả sử là mình sẽ Insert hai sinh viên
cùng 1 lúc thì mình sẽ làm như thế nào
để không ạ
Cái cái bài toán ở đây ừ ừ
vì thế bài toán ở đây nó khá phức tạp
AE theo kiểu như thế này ờ
à à
Vì
vậy bây giờ đấy thường là mình sẽ làm
theo cách kiểu nhà cho nó dễ đi ra xử là
mình đi Shop mình Mị mình có thể là
Issac
nhiều sinh viên vào cùng một lớp Giả sử
Mỹ rất 6 sinh viên và cùng một lớp đúng
không ạ 6 sinh viên và cả lớp này đi đồ
ngoại thì chuẩn nhá chuẩn hairogy của
thực tế Đúng đó là mình sẽ in xuất làm
bạn rồi loại đi mỗi bạn
đúng đúng đúng ạ
ơi các bạn hãy hình dung bài toán đây
không ạ Đó là do sự mà mình đi rất 6
Sinh viên vào lớp Amway mà rõ là số của
chồng 150 ạ thì mình theo lôgic mình cần
làm là gì ạ Mình sẽ chỉn suốt năm bạn
đúng ạ và thông báo là một bạn bị lỗi
đúng ạ
cái cách đấy mình thời gian mình vẫn làm
được như nó sẽ lại phức tạp một tí đúng
không ạ Có làm cái kiểu đơn giản hơn một
tí đó là mình
Ừ mình cư đến kiểm tra xem là có bao
nhiêu sinh viên vào lớp ABC rét đã đầu
ngon nếu mà không Nếu mà kiểu nó bị vượt
ngưỡng mình thông báo lỗi luôn để thường
là cách đấy nhiều phần mềm bây giờ lại
đang áp dụng theo kiểu là làm thế chứng
anh kết hợp việc là cho người dùng kiểm
tra lại chắc chắn mới đúng hết đã ở to
cho mày nhưng xét một lượt hãy cậu thế
Ừ đúng rồi chuẩn là bây giờ mình sẽ phải
đến đến số lượng sinh viên rồi mình roi
các hư thứ bởi vì vẫn bài toán ở đây là
vẫn bài toán mình phải kiểm tra xem số
lỗ chồng có thỏa mãn hay không mà đúng
không ạ thì bây giờ xử lý rất nhiều thì
tự nhiên mình phải đếm nóng bạn phải đến
xem là bao nhiêu sinh viên sẽ vào lớp A
bao nhiêu sinh viên sẽ vào lớp bê cái sổ
chỗ trống của lớp A và lớp B đấy nó có
đủ thỏa mãn hay không đúng không ạ Để em
ý xốt vào
em gái
thì các bạn hiểu được Nãy giờ mình nói
không
nói cái đấy xong khó hiểu quá không ạ
anh hiểu được câu này đã chưa cắt hiểu
mình sẽ Cốt nhạc hiểu được cái quy chỉnh
quy trình mình xử lý một bài toán đi ạ
Đóng lại
vì số lượng Xem giám đốc
đến đoạn nâng cao tạo được ok ở
chỗ nào Bây giờ mình cần lấy
đầu tiên mình cần như hôm trước mình làm
thôi đó là mình sẽ đến đến xem với từng
lớp đúng không ạ
select mã lớp này và cao sao cho này
for instance
ai mình chạy thử nhé
xin lỗi gì
ừ ừ
anh cao sao à Như Cuba muốn mở lớp à
khi đó về mình như shop này
Em nói như này đúng không anh sẽ áp là
số lượng sinh viên
sẽ thêm này tên rất dài Đông ạ cho dễ
hiểu à
anh chạy lên à
khi đó nghĩa là bây giờ sẽ có hai bạn
bảo lớp 10 ạ đấy
anh mới chịu mình mình sẽ nhìn xếp theo
kiểu từng lớp một đã nhé Ừ thôi tí ở sẽ
nhiều lớp cùng một lúc nữa Nói chung là
cứ phải nâng cao nâng cao dần không ạ
thì ở trong trường hợp này các bạn thấy
là ok số lượng sinh viên như này chắc
chắn là lớp kia thỏa mãn được rồi không
ạ một cái lớp kia có thận năm mà nó
không ạ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ thuần là
à vì sao sáng cái số lượng sẽ thêm này
với cái số chỗ trận số chỗ trống kia là
không ạ
có những cách nào đơn giản hơn cách nói
đơn giản hơn nó sẽ như thế này
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
an toàn bộ Cái này nó sẽ là 1 bảng
h i này ạ
o0o
à à
I đặc điểm Mimi nó nghĩ xem à Cách cách
nào để mà giải thích các bạn nói dễ hiểu
nhất
Ừ
Rồi
tặng bỏ cái này sang đây đã nhé mình xin
phép Dạy cái này trước rồi
bỏ bỏ bỏ Lấy kiểu thì mình sẽ dùng thôi
Đây mình cứ đi suốt một bạn trước đi
nhiều mạn theo cách không không phải
nông dân mà như vừa nãy đi
Ừ để các bạn dễ hình dung đã
cách để máy xác không Nông dân Các bạn
nhớ cách in xuất hiện của nông dân vừa
nãy nó gì không ạ Nó là mình có bao
nhiêu cột thì mình sẽ đi krabi như cột
để mí shop vào đấy ông ạ Còn nhiều không
ạ Mình sẽ đi claire như thế này mã
bằng
select mã for Master Các bạn nhớ kế đoạn
điệp khúc nào ạ Mình sẽ đi clip bấy
nhiêu cái như thế này đúng không ạ sau
đó thì mình sẽ Giả sử có chấm nhầm dám
đây nhá Tôi giả sử mình sẽ is that into
sinh viên xong rồi mình Mã như này đúng
không ạ sau đó thì value xong rồi lại
điệp khúc mà như này không ạ Còn nếu mạ
thì đi claire như thế
rất nhiều thế không tốt cũng như là kiểu
Các bạn thấy lặp đi lặp lại nó bạn chất
lấy từ bảng nghĩ sẽ thật thôi mà tại sao
mình không lấy hết từ bạn sẽ thật tự mí
rất vào đúng ạ
nhà mình có thể làm thế mà mình sẽ làm
đúng kiểu nhà luôn ấy
a slack xào forecasted là xong cái tuổi
trông rất ngắn rất dễ hiểu được gọi là
sợi rất vào sinh viên lấy toàn bộ từ
bảng tin tức là sau chạy thử nhé chạy
được em ạ
ở đây mình chạy thử các bạn xem nó tin
là đang chưa có sinh viên ở đông thì sợ
lắm
ở đó
ở đoạn này dễ hiểu đoạn này thì dễ hiểu
không ạ ở đoạn này theo chỉ đơn giản là
đưa mình có Thậm chí cái này hỗ trợ ý
rất nhiều nhé Chị sẽ nhiều Non nhé để
hai Chuẩn đấy
thăm lớp khác đi đúng ạ Thế mua bạn nữa
đi
anh cũng là anh Tuấn là anh đấy phân
thân anh học cả lớp 1 Đi đúng không
Delete bạn đi lễ rồi xóa đi này
anh nghe này
vi phạm nhí xuất thử lại sinh viên à
em chạy lại
Sau đó các bạn thấy cơ à
em không cần phải đi claire và dòng thủ
công giống như vừa nãy anh đã cốt chị
rất dạng như này có bao nhịn có bao
nhiêu is xuất thì mình sẽ lách bấy nhiêu
và Insert vào trong bảo sinh viên không
Còn ghi ở trên cục nữa đứa nằm không ạ
Và từ đây mình mới nâng lên nó thành như
này bây giờ cái cái này các bạn vừa thấy
vừa thấy mình lấy nó lấy
cách lấy mã lớp các tự xứ để mà kiểm tra
đúng không ạ Vì sẽ kiểm tra theo ạ
ở với cái Mà lớp đấy xem nó có kiểu thỏa
mãn hay không Vân Vân không ạ
có ai nó sẽ như thế này
em copy lại này
a bà B mình sẽ
biến nó thành một bảng và Fi em ạ Và bây
giờ mình sẽ Shake sao form
Ừ mạng lớp trước đi
ờ ờ
Ừ rồi cả cái cúp này nhé
On Y chấm mã lớp đúng ạ bằng lớp chấm Mã
A và anh em hoặc quen được mình nói dùng
que quê xuống chỗ chấm
số nhỏ hơn số lượng y chấm số lượng sinh
viên dạy thêm đó có lệnh nó sẽ như thế
này bây giờ bắt đầu đến lúc này cái này
bài toán ở đây nó sẽ làm ở gì mình sẽ
lấy xem đoạn lấy toàn bộ các lớp có số
chấm đúng ạ ạ
à à đâu phải lớn hơn đi Đúng rồi phải
lớn hơn một cái số lượng sinh viên lớn
hơn hoặc bằng lớn bằng số lượng sinh
viên sẽ thêm cái chạy nè
ở đây mình chạy được ăn sớm nhé
Đi học bây giờ mình
Ừ Ok như thế này giả sử là mình sẽ à
Em in sót lại và
chắc lại phải xóa rồi Ừ tôi nên tạo 1
cái code để mà xóa nhanh cái đoạn này
cho ý rất lạnh nhanh cứ phải đi xát lại
hơn mất công nhận Xin lỗi các bạn
ở đây đánh trống trơn nhé trong trường
hợp này là tô Insert vào
công sẽ thấy tôi yên giấc hay bạn vào
lớp một này một bạn lớp 2 tự nhiên cái
này sẽ dẫn thỏa mãn rồi đúng không ạ
ý là như này
thì các bạn thấy à
Anh lớp 1 vào lớp 2 số lượng sinh viên
sẽ thêm như thế này không ở đây gì cả
đúng không ạ nhưng bây giờ giả sử là
mình sẽ đi xuất thêm một bạn nữa là
Anh Tuấn hacker ạ
anh lần này bạn ấy vào lớp 3 chẳng hạn
Chắc chắn là lớp này số lượng sinh viên
xuống chỗ trống Các bạn nhớ không ạ chỗ
trống nó là gì ạ chỗ trống mà không Tất
cả không thể easiest bạn đấy vào trong
đất thứ ba đúng không ạ sẽ thử nhé đó có
ông thấy nó vẫn sẽ Chỉ ra mỗi hai lớp
này thôi ông ạ Mình sẽ không ra lớp 13
Vậy sao khi số chỗ trống nó không hề
thỏa mãn việc lớn hơn hoặc bằng số lượng
sinh viên sẽ thêm số lượng sinh viên sẽ
thêm lần này nó là một mà chỗ trống nó
là không không không để lớn lên bằng một
được đúng đúng ạ Nó sẽ không ra đó
Chị Hai Lúa không
Ừ
nhưng mà đoạn này các bạn thấy mình mới
chỉ xe lách thôi Mẹ làm gì đâu đúng ạ
thì bây giờ các bạn thấy cái việc mình
vừa sẽ lấy cái cốt ở điểm gì để lấy ra
được cái lớp thỏa mãn lớp thỏa mãn việc
in such nóng ạ thì là mình lại làm tiếp
mình sẽ lấy lớp chấm mã này à
khi sex
em chạy lại này à mình mình đi phát lại
gọi xe mà đó thì còn lớp 1 và lớp 2 và
mình thỏa mãn đúng ạ lớp Một lớp hai
mình thỏa mãn rồi mình làm gì tiếp
Ừ thì mình sẽ chỉ insaat những cái bạn
sinh viên
Em thuộc lớp Một lớp hai thỏa mãn thôi
nó sẽ như thế này
I Insert into
sinh viên snacks
Vì sao phone instead các bạn nếu cái câu
hồi nãy không ạ
Ừ Rồi mình sẽ Where mã lớp In nằm trong
các cụm này
đó với rồng nếu anh có thể bảo là rất là
đúng
thì nó sẽ như thế nào có việc
thì các bạn nhớ câu này vừa nãy mình có
ghi không ạ thì lần này mình sẽ cho mạ
lớp chỉ nằm trong kể cái cái danh sách
lớp Một lớp hai này thôi nó như này in
nằm trong đó
anh chạy ạ
Anh An ninh thủ in sót lại
A chạy
em heo không có tuần hacker đúng không
có tấn hai câu được tôi kéo Kim Chi Mới
Ừ Ok chị ạ ạ
Ông ngoại ra hơi lũ thật
cho tất cả cụm này bản chất nó là gì cả
cụm cả cụ này vừa rồi mình cần này mã
lắm không ạ lầy mã lớp hợp lệ
Ừ đúng rồi nó Safari Các bạn thấy là nó
là
select nằm lòng nhân selec nó Safari
thằng con
nhưng mà thế này mới chỉ áp dụng cho ok
Các bạn thấy được là bây giờ vừa áp dụng
được cho cả lớp chỗ trống mà không ạ
nhưng nó vẫn chưa update thì cả Không ạ
bây giờ update thì như thế nào đúng ạ
thì nó lại giống cái bài toán hôm trước
các bạn nhớ chích lâu hôm trước mình học
thì có gì cập rồi nó mình sẽ là update
lớp sét số chỗ trống bằng
trò chuyện - bạn đi bằng y chấm số lượng
sinh viên Các bạn nhớ đoạn này sau đó
thì before này
lại for copy đúng ý hết cái đoạn ở trên
này lại như thế này
anh
nghe này là được
a form of Joy thứ thứ này
ở đó
Anh thấy bây giờ mày Ông còn thấy lũ hơn
không ạ
ta chạy nha
Ừ đi lại
anh cứ sát lại này thuộc mệt mỏi đoạn
này quá lại phải tạm hồ sơ lưu thôi lỡ
rồi
từ đầu tiên sẽ lấy lại cho chắc này 550
ạ
khi buồn lại nay sao này
Em có áo rượu ạ
anh cũng rẽ mà nó không ạ Dễ mà
ở đoạn Delete như mình đã nói chi cơ
Insert trong tác dụng này trong bài toán
này không cần áp dụng Delete Đúng không
ạ
nhưng mà
ở những nhưng mà lại sợ mấy ông cái hiểu
cái đoạn sub theo kiểu nhiều Nhiều này
rồi không ạ
Anh Hiểu hiểu à
giới thiệu phần nó nhá Tôi không thể bảo
mày không hiểu hết được nhiều hết thì
thành siêu nhân quá đoạn này tôi xem lại
đội ta thấy hơi lú
Tôi không biết đoạn này có thể tối ưu
được hay không Nhưng mà tôi thấy bạn này
trông có phải nói thứ nhất là đang đúng
rồi Đã thì xem nó thì tối rồi không nữa
thì chưa biết luôn lâu lắm mở rộng động
lại phần này à
Ừ Ok Còn bây giờ
mấy ông có tài chưa để tôi dậy Nốt Cần
update số lượng nhiều À à
à à
anh Alo có ai chưa
Em sắp này thứ Ba ở có khi áp dụng cái
Asus này nhanh được này
Ừ ừ khóa rồi sợ
em chỉ hơi bị ngược lặng Tí và việc là
khi mà đi led thì mình kiểm tra hư thôi
không ạ
anh không thể mới ông bình luận gì nữa
ờ ờ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi sẽ thả nó cái này là cái khó
cái này cái bụi cần đưa buổi cuối của
fei chuyên sâu rồi nữa Đỡ buồn phải khói
chứ mày không thể mong dễ được dễ mấy
ông ấy thất vọng Nói thẳng như thế nếu
không phải mong bữa mày rất khó đúng
không ạ
Khi bữa mày khó thì ông xem lại 3 4 lần
kiểu gì ông cũng sẽ vỡ dần ra má không ạ
à à
Ừ cái việc update này đâu để mình sẽ lại
nhé
chưa bao giờ sử bài toán theo mỹ nhân sẽ
lại sợ lại làm lu quá à
Ừ mình cũng vừa mới tiêm xong thành ra
là mình cũng đang hơi bị đốm thì sang
cho nó hỏng thì mình xin lỗi các bạn
tiên thì ra tin tưởng qua ở nhiều hôm
nay mới có vẻ nhấn Vậy thôi ngủ ngủ từ
hôm qua đến giờ đấy còn chưa ăn uống
nhiều ạ
ờ ờ
xổ số ba bây giờ để đầu tiên là số của
chồng nó bằng 5 này
chỉ số chống thay bằng không ngoài đúng
ạ bây giờ sự mình cập nhật Số lượng số
sinh viên từ đây sang đây này
ừ ừ
Ừ từ đây sang đây sản không được Bởi vì
sẽ sẵn chỗ trống này mà không ạ
Cho tôi có phải làm
thử để mua ra sự của 3 sinh viên này Đây
là sự năm này
à à
khi mà không có sinh viên nào biết lớp
này thì mình sẽ cập nhật 3 sinh viên vào
bên này thì bên này sẽ đổi lại nó thành
22 và năm đó ông ạ hòa nhập 532 đúng
không ạ này
Ừ Ok dạo này gần đây là hồi trước mình
có nhờ một bạn sinh viên là bạn đấy chia
thành danh sách phát để mà các bạn xem
lại từng đoạn từng đoạn cho
nếu mà ông nào chỉ muốn xem đoạn nào
đoạn nào thì có thể cắt tua nhanh đến
đấy nhưng dạo này bạn sinh viên này cũng
bận nữa rồi
chờ tôi tự xem lại tự chia vậy
nó cả có nhiều việc hoặc là hãy quên đã
ạ Bây giờ giả sử mình cập nhật như này
số lượng ngay giờ sự mình à
Lúc đầu là sự tay có 6 sinh viên
số lượng Lúc đầu như thế này
và sau đó thì ở đây Tổng cộng của sáu
này à
hôm nay Ê Phương mình đội hết nó sao lại
như này à
Ừ thì mình cần là tệ
Ê mày đã không này đấy vợ năm này
anh nhắc lại 6 này cái này sẽ -1 chẳng ạ
ạ
Ừ
mình vẫn phải cao mình cũng phải đến
đúng không ạ đến ở đây là mình sẽ phải
đếm xem
tay mình thể chạy thử đoạn này cho nhau
ừ ừ
anh cứ chạy lần lượt là kiểu xảy ra thôi
sẽ xa form chị sẽ lực này
mình bắt đầu thú
sẽ sao form B thật này à
chào cả nhà
Ừ ok
Anh đang trống như này sinh viên thật sự
bây giờ mình sẽ cho tất cả sinh viên
sang lớp thứ ba là sáng lại sẽ update mà
lớp bằng ba không có que gì cả đúng
không ạ Nếu mà update như này
Ừ nếu bà biết như này
thì các bạn sẽ thấy à đương nhiên bê bây
giờ đang chưa đổi được
em đổi toàn bộ lớp 3 này mình sẽ thạch
cao cao toàn bộ tất cả các
sinh viên sẽ chuyện giá gốc thứ ba
khi sex
à
không để xem nha Đổi sáng tất cả sinh
viên trong lớp thứ ba chỉ đứng tên mình
kiểm tra xem à thỏa mãn hay không đúng
không ạ
à à
3000 mình nhớ hồi đấy mình dậy sinh viên
mình cũng sẽ không áp dụng theo cách của
ít đâu mình sẽ dạy theo kiểu như thế này
cơ á
à à
chị cũng sẽ áp dụng đúng như thế này
update love xét các thử như thế này
anh nói chung là mình sẽ copy cái đoạn
này
cho Starex out for a
Ừ cái cái cái đoạn này thì các bạn hình
dung rồi cái đoạn này nó là số lượng
sinh viên sẽ thêm không ạ khi mình trả
lại các bạn dễ hình dung nhé
khi sex
bạn trong trường hợp này các bạn thể sẽ
không ra cả lớp nào tôi rõ là lớp thứ ba
rồi nó sẽ không thỏa mãn còn lớp thứ 2
thì mày làm được thỏa mãn này đúng ạ Bởi
vì số chồng nó bốn số lượng sinh viên sẽ
là ba nên nó thỏa mãn Còn với lớp thứ ba
nó không giải mã nó sẽ ra như thế này
ngoạn
ạ Bây giờ mình à
đi học mình có thai nó lại bằng lớp thứ
hai các bạn dễ dễ xem đã bên mình cần
lấy mã lớp này
cách lấy mã lớp để mình cập nhật giống
như là cái vụ vừa rồi thôi ông ạ
bộ phim sẽ update
sinh viên à
à à
ừ ừ
3000 lẽ update như mình nói lại delete
và Insert thì nó sẽ tốt hơn mình sẽ lại
ít
into sinh viên
thế giống hệt câu chuyện này tôi nghĩ là
chẳng khác gì đâu sao for instance Where
mã Lớp in
Ừ thế giới mã
Trần Mã Ý
ừ ừ
à à
thế này và mình cũng đi lễ đi không
Delete From A
cô sinh viên
Ừ có nghĩa có khi ở trẻ áp dụng theo
dòng hết cái à
Ừ cái ở trên kia là chạy được đấy Không
cần nó phức tạp quá à
chị sẽ thử nhé
à Tôi đang nghĩ làm thuốc tạp chưa
thử phát này à
dù thời tiết ở lớp thứ ba thử xem được
không
anh bay xử me sinh viên rồi
Ừ
bắt tại sao máy bay nhỉ à các bạn I
stood
a deadphone mạn Love in
à à
ở lớp trầm mã số lượng sinh viên sẽ thêm
thì tại sao bạn lại bay được nghỉ tôi bị
sai sai ở đâu đợi tới thì chuẩn bị ngáo
quá à
à à
Em ăn hết đoạn này nữa con xuống kB
ừ ừ
ở
Samsung KC
Ừ ai cũng sẽ đến lúc nào không ạ con
xuống KC
từ hôm Men in Asia
Vì sao đó à
à à
Hà Thanh Xuân Ca Đúng rồi nhỉ
Ừ cái hợp mọi khi mình cho đoạn này biến
hàng bình luận được mà nhỉ
Ừ anh em chú thích chú thích thì mày
nghỉ
là
sao rốt điên à
em thông cảm mình hình như mình đang đến
giường áo ơi xin lỗi các bạn
à à
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
ở Samsung ca Samsung à
3000 ra sinh viên làm à à Rồi rồi Mình
hiểu tại sao sai rồi đoạn vừa rồi mình
delete Mình bị nhầm âm Ok mình xin lỗi
cái bạn này em đúng mình khiếu đoạn quay
ở đây thấy ra Nói đi lecture hết à
về chính sách này mình nghĩ là chạy được
rồi đi suốt này sẽ được mình sẽ que bạn
lớp như này là xong
mình tin quái chạy luôn này thử nhé Thử
thì biết đúng không ạ
á đù á đù á
- redhead in
xuất lại vào lớp này
chị xem xem lại sinh viên lớp nhé Chắc
lại sinh viên lớp này Ok đúng không ạ bơ
mình sẽ ăn xơ vào như này không ạ sẽ lại
sinh viên lớp son nữa này các bạn thấy
là
Anh Tuấn hacker sáng không thêm về vợ
làm lớp Thứ Ba không được Tại đúng không
ạ phần nãy mình làm rồi à bê mình cần
cập nhật hết sinh viên vào lớp thứ 3 cả
ạ thìa sẵn à chuẩn là những sinh viên
này bắt buộc phải giữ nguyên đúng không
ạ
phụ nữ sinh viên này dễ giữ nguyên ở như
thế nào chả này
khi đó các bạn thấy con sẽ giữ nguyên
chọn gì thay đổi cả đúng ạ Thế bây giờ
tương tự Thế bây giờ mình sẽ
em đổi tất cả sinh viên sang lớp thứ hai
là em ạ thì sẽ như thế nào
Ông ngoại chạy nha
xin lỗi à
à à
anh đau để xem Tại sao lỗi nào mà bạn là
đã ký kết kỳ một liên quan đến khóa
chính
Ừ tao mình xem lại nhé
Ừ em ngủ đi em ạ
I Delete for sinh viên về mã lớp
Ừ thế thì mình phải xé rách lại có đoạn
này cho chắc đi thì sẽ check lại đoạn
này đi Ừ
mà
copy toàn bộ cái này ra cái này đi à
em chạy lại
ê ê đê ê ê
à À rồi mình hay dùng rồi à
ở cái đoạn này nó hơi bị phức tạp một tí
đoạn này là mình cần lấy mạng lớp cũ
anh cài Cả lớp mình mình đang lấy mình
lấy từ 7 xuất thật thì da mình lấy
Ừ mình mới chỉ đang xóa những cái thằng
từ bản cũ
vì vậy
ở
đoạn này nhá cái đoạn này mình đang lấy
từ bảng mỗi từ từ mình sẽ cập nhật xanh
cái gì thành ra là thế cái dữ liệu cũng
không Xóa đi
sau khi mà cái này thỏa mãn rồi này tôi
tên là khi thỏa mãn không ạ ạ
ừ ừ
a
Note II
à à
khi sex
Ừ
tôi có khi là tôi phải xin phép mấy ông
là buổi sau tối chữa thì câu này đi Tôi
thấy tôi đang đùa quá rồi Tôi sợ làm với
ông lũ thêm mất tạm chắc phải tạm dừng
tay lại
tôi xin phép đang Hơi lùn tra ban đầu
choáng vào cái ba xinh rồi
Các bạn chọn như thế bà Tôi đói nữa
ở tạm cất cái này sang buổi hôm sau điện
Ừ ai cũng sẽ có lúc mà như thế thôi mặt
ngoại mình dân công nghệ thì mình vẫn
khẳng định đó là không dây công nghệ
mình không thể một phát ra được luôn
nóng ạ Các bạn xem xem lại cái á
10 bài tập sao mày tập sao mày Ông ngồi
mòi được Dạo này cũng cũng được cho mấy
ông Mười mà những bài tập hôm nay mình
sẽ khác một tí ờ ờ Các bạn thấy mấy buổi
trước mà mình thường ra mình không Chữa
bài tập cho các bạn bởi vì là
hầu như tôi toàn bảo mấy ông Cốt lại
nhưng còn bài hôm nay thì tôi sẽ không
cho mấy ông bị ngoài được chốt lại như
thế Tôi sẽ
sẽ có bài tập mới các bạn cũng sẽ phải
tự làm tự làm cái mới đấy chứ không
Không dựa bài bài cũ ở đâu ạ
em còn Cầu xã câu này tra để tôi về xem
lại đã
ở tuổi mình ngỡ mình làm được mấy con
này hết rồi nghe kiểu gì cũng mò lại thì
chị sẽ hiểu thôi thôi tạm
Âu Mỹ ở tạm cho các bạn nghỉ nhé mình
cũng xóa nó rồi tặng Chào bạn nhé
ừ ừ